ですから ブッダの教えは革命論なんですね
心により支配されて世界が成り立つという言葉は革命的な言葉なんです
ブッダの場合は体によって
仏教では体によって心が汚れるということは言えますけど
相互依存だから でも お釈迦様はもっと厳しく言うんですね
いえ 心が全部支配しているんだと
生きるとは環境を認識して
環境により起こる感覚を変えていくことですね
生きるって何ですかね？生きるっていうのは
我々は見たり聞いたり感じたりすることでしょ
そうすると 感じる ちょっと空気が冷たい
どうする？空気を暖かくするんです
あ 冷えた冷えた冷えたと思って
それが生きることでしょ
ジャガイモを持って食ってみたら
あんまり美味しくないんですね
感覚で もうもう砂もついてるし
泥もあるし 感覚は良くない
それで洗っちゃう それ環境変化でしょ
洗って食ってみたらまだまずい
それで茹でてみる まあいくらかマシですけど
まだつまらない そうするとまた塩をかけたり
また油で炒めたり くっちゃくっちゃいろんなことをやってます
ジャガイモの料理にしても
もうもうもう数え切れない切らないほどジャガイモの料理ありますね
スマッシュポテトからね
もうポテトチップスからね
フレンチフライとかね
あるわあるわ それで人間が環境を変えているんですね
環境を変えることができたのは
認識できるんだからなんです
ビルを作るわ 車を作るわ
動物も同じことやってますよ
動物はビルは作りませんが
鳥だったらかなり精密な巣を作ったりする
だからどちらが偉いということでもないし
だから鳥たちは余計なことは作らない
人間も巣は作らないでしょ
その能力もないんです
じゃあ皆様に枝の上で釘一本も使わないで
糸絶対使わないで 枝だけで卵を大事に置いておける場所を作れる
風が吹いても大丈夫やと
できないでしょ それちょっと針金でなんとかするんだから
大失敗 カラスは針金使いません
ただ枝の上で置いとくだけ
だから相当のエンジニアたちですよ
だからしかし カラスにはこんなビルは作れませんね
これ我々人間に必要な必要だから
人間の都合によって人間が物事を作っていて
ですから生きることで我々は感じる
環境まず 1 環境を感じる 2
環境を変える それやってるんです
動物もやってるんです
ミミズもやってるんです
ミミズはどれほど環境を変えるかというとね
すごいでしょう だから植物は元気で成長するでしょうね
ミミズのおかげで で 感覚を変えるために認識を変えなくてはならないので
入る情報を変えるんです
だから我々は何をするのかというと
これは結論的な言葉で
ちょっと難しいんですけど
理解するのは 感覚を変えたいんですね
例えば 外へ出まった 冷った風が体に触れた
すっごく寒かった そこで感覚を変えたいんです
寒いというね この震える感覚
嫌です それで寒いという感覚
暖かいという感覚に変えたいでしょ
それで環境を変えなくちゃいけないんです
それがあの情報を変えることなんです
変える情報を変えるんです
例えば 外で体がずっと震えたら
何か何かもう一つ上着をつけたりする
それで体に入る情報が変わったんです
もう冷たい空気は触れません
だから入るインプットする情報を変えたんです
まあ複雑に聞こえますけど
単純です あのパソコン画面で出てくる結果が嫌だからデータを変えるのです
それでデータインプットするデータ変えればモニター画面も変わります
で 科学と経済の発展変化はその結果です
この発展という言葉を入れ
私は変化という言葉を使いたいんですけど
科学と科学と経済の発展というのは
この結果で我々はデータを変えているんです
体にインプットするデータを変えているんです
その結果 社会が変わっているんです
で 生きるものは自分の都合で環境を変えるんですね
軽く言えば カラスはカラスの都合で
ネズミはネズミの都合で
人間は人間の都合で環境を変えているんです
論理的にはみんなデータを変えているんです
体に触れるデータを で
命とは心認識だというと
一切の生命は基本的に自由な存在であり
平等であり 誰の子分でも誰に支配されて生きているわけでもないんですね
だからブッダから見れば
命というのは心なんです
認識なんです 魂っていう言葉で言ってるものじゃないんです
俺の魂っていうのは心かと
俺の魂っていうのはただの認識かと
わかるとどうなるんですかね
一人一人が自由ということになるんです
ミミズの魂はミミズの認識でしょ
だからミミズは勝手に認識するんであって
私にはどうすることもできないんです
じゃあ皆様 できるならミミズに赤い色を見せてあげてください
できることなら できることなら
ミミズに醤油の味を味わせてみてください
できないでしょ ミミズにはミミズなりの認識システムがあります
だから それぞれ生命は自由であるという話なんです
誰が作ったわけでもなく
誰の支配下で動いているわけでもないんです
神がこうやって腰に手をかけて
ミミズに見えないようにしてやるぞと
やってないんです ミミズには目がないだけ
自分が自分の主人でありという言葉は
一切の宗教が語る教えに正反対になります
ですから ブッダが言う自分が自分の主人であるということは
世にあった ある これから起こるすべての宗教に対して
もう原子爆弾なんです
今も日本で新しい宗教は生まれつつでしょ
みんな原始時代の同じ宗教なんです
我はブッダの生まれ変わりだと言っている人の宗教も
石器時代からやっていた同じ宗教なんです
絶対的神を信仰するという
どうってことないんです
だから我は我の主人でありという言葉は
もうすごい爆弾的な言葉なんです
はい 心が創造者だというと
それは極端な反宗教論になります
だからブッダが言った心は
創造者でありということは
これは極端的な反宗教論なんです
私の理解では だから私は仏教は宗教ではないっていうのが
あの人の宣伝文句やと思ってるんだけど
それじゃないんです もう本当に実質的に
これはもう宗教ではないところじゃないんです
反宗教論なんです これはヨーロッパで流行っているエティーさんとはもうずいぶんわけが違います
あの人はガチャガチャガチャ宗教を批判しているだけで
だから何って思ってないし
人間にどう生きるべきかという道を教えてないし
ただ宗教は嫌いだだけで
宗教が言ってることはもうむちゃくちゃやとか
そのその通りですけど
でもあんたどうする？っていうことに答えがないでしょ
宗教は嫌いかもしれませんだけど
もう悩むとこは悩むんだから
落ち込むとこは落ち込むんだから
自信がないときはどうしようもないんだから
だから どのように生きるべきか
生きるとは何やと こういう風にやりましょうということも科学的に言ってほしいんです
それは誰もやってないんです
だからブッダの無神論というのは並大抵のものじゃないんです
だから仏教はもう極限に
本当に無神論ですよ 釈迦さんは問題を起こさず
一切の実体論 宗教概念を否定しているんです
そういうすごいことをやってましたから
お釈迦様が心に対する定義はちょっとちょっと微妙に波を打って語ってるんです
では心が偉いのかと はい
それで仏教から我々は立った立場は心って偉いぞと
だって心が全部作ってるんだから
心が支配者だから偉いに決まってるでしょ
肉体よりは はい 次の問題は
ポイントは では心が偉いのかということなんです
でお釈迦様はなんか別なこと言うんですね
創造者まで持ち上げたが
心は偉くないんです お釈迦様は心を創造者まで持ち上げたんです
これも実証しながらなんです
しかし 心そのものが偉くないんです
揺れ動く 逃げ回る 肉体に徹底的に依存している
瞬時に変わる 決して一定しない
つかみにくい 制御しがたい
情報も誤認する働きなんです
やれやれと この神様が
この親分がこんなもんなんです
だからその複雑さ理解してください
ブッダの論理はもうかなりもう悟って言ってるんだからね
時々私のおしゃべり方でね
すごいシンプルだと思いますけど
まあ結構大変なところはあります
はい これでまとめて言うと
世の中で絶対的な強い偉いのは心なんです
が 心そのものが偉いかというと
心そのものも腰抜けなんです
揺れ動くは 逃げ回るは
肉体に徹底的に依存しているは
ちょっとしたことで変わっちゃう
ほんのちょっとで心が変わる
なので一定しない 何かやろうかなと思って
え やめたという人間でしょ
我々は はい これから勉強する
あ 嫌になっちゃったとかね
こんな心なんですよ これから勉強する
絶対徹底的にやっちゃうぞと思ったらできるのに
やっぱり心はまあ腰抜けでできないんです
刺激に飢える 心はいつでも刺激欲しいということなんです
感情に支配されてろくでもない働きです
偉くないんです 感情に支配されています
はい それから因縁の関係も心にあります
心は自立できません おかしいでしょうね
もう創造者なのに 支配者なのに
自立できません これ 世界見ても同じことでしょ
天皇陛下はすごく偉いんだけど
何の自立もできないんでしょ
身を置きできん 皆様よりはものすごい惨めな生き方をしなくちゃいけないんです
極限に 今日誕生日だから
このテレビを見ないで
私はこのいろいろ皇室の方々の言葉を聞いていたんですね
やっぱり私たちみたいに自由にダラダラダラダラ喋らないんですね
ちゃんとセクションごとに止めながら
もう原稿を読み上げる感じでね
いわゆるフォーシラブル
フォーシラブルでカットして喋ってるんですね
かわいそう 普通日本語はね
まあ丁寧にプロが喋る場合はちゃんとフレーズごとに切るんだけど
我々は普通そうしないでしょ
例えば我々は普通にはそういたしませんというふうにカットして喋ってわかりやすいかもしれませんだけど
普通はそうしませんね
やっぱり向こうはそうじゃないでしょうに
だからまあ偉いんだけど
トップなんですが 実際の状況はかなり気をつけなくちゃいけないという
心も同じなんです 因縁により現れるものです
で 例を出します 色が目に触れたら視覚が生じる
音が耳に触れたら聴覚が生じる
当たり前でしょ 何も目に触れないから何も見えないでしょ
何も耳に触れなかったらね
聞こえないでしょ だから俺が聞いてるんだとかね
自慢できる？音がだからなかったらかわいそう
何も知らない心が だからかなり因縁なんですね
情報によって心が変わる
それから情報によって心が変わる
目に入ったものは あ そこはすげえと思ったら
心がすごい感動を覚える
覚えるんですね なんだこれ
嫌と思ったら 心はずっともう弱くなっちゃうんですね
だから 目を開けただけで心はどうなるか知ったものじゃないんです
例えば これから車に乗ってちょっとドライブに行くと
楽しそうと思ってもダメですよ
どうなるかわからない
道路で何を見るか それによって心がぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ広げるんです
揺れ動くんです はい それからフレーズごとに切って喋ります
その 感情が起きたら それに伴う妄想が起こるんです
そこで何か見る びっくりする美しさに
そこで感情が生まれる
それから妄想が始まるんです
あ この公園もすごい綺麗ですけど
でもこの間 新潟に行ったところでね
こんなもんじゃなくても 20倍大きい公園でしたけどね
どこまででも やっぱりそういえば
イギリスの庭園はね ちゃんと幾何学的に作ってあってね
あれもなかなかイギリス人の味でね
違いますねとか あれやこれやとか
妄想は次から次へと それから日本庭園とイギリスの庭園の対話論とかできたりとかね
もう切りがないんです
あるいは目を開いたら何か人が見える
見えた人はどうもうちのお嫁さんに微妙に似ている
それだけ それで感情が湧いてくる
あんなお嫁はねとかね
そういうわけで 感情この感情が起きたら
それに伴う妄想が生まれてくるんです
体に冷たい風が触れても
暖かい風が触れても心が変わってしまうんです
全然偉くないし あまりにも惨めで依存です
皆様が心変えるためには
すごい簡単 このカーテンを開けても変わります
ちぎってこのパソコンの電源切っただけでも
切られただけでもガコンと変わっちゃうんです
ほんのちょっとのことで心は変わるんです
しかし 心は自力的に自力で生じる
生きるではなくて生じる
で 物質も心もエネルギーなんです
で エネルギーとは限りなく変化して変わる働きですね
で 流れる情報によって心も認識ですね
変わるが 外の情報に触れることがなくても
自力で内の情報によって次の心が生じるんです
そこで簡単に言います
何かあるならば見える
何か音があるならば聞こえる
それで頭を回転 頭が回転するということは
見えるものも聞くものも嗅ぐものも味わうものも触れるものもなくなっちゃうと死んじゃうんですかね
死にません 心は自分の中の情報で回転するんです
すごいシンプルです 皆様方はあの 24時間生きていても
これで 8時間カットしても
あの残り時間はどれぐらいでしたっけ？ 16時間ですね
で  16時間ちゃんと見て聞いて味わってますかね
ないんです ほとんど妄想なんです
時間は だから生きる時間足らないんです
仕事にも時間足らないんです
妄想すごい だから妄想って別に外からは何もないでしょ
こちらに座って目を閉じれば妄想できる
お風呂に入ってでも妄想できる
お風呂に入ってアメリカのことも
あの 9.11事件のことを思い出すこともできる
だから心は自力で回転するんです
すごいエネルギーなんです
だから この原子の働きと同じ原子とかウランとかね
働きと同じなんです だからウランとか
このもうもう 何て言いますか
このあるいはこの核反応を起こすと
自分の中ですごいことやっちゃいますけど
外にも影響を与えることはできます
で ウランの核反応を起こすために
外からちょこっとした引き金は必要なんです
ウランがあっただけでもう爆破しませんよ
貯蔵に待っただけでもういきなり爆弾ってないんです
ただそのままいるだけ
しかし ちょこっといじっちゃうと
そこで爆破になりますけど
そこで内で自分自身で働くんですよ
自分で自分を壊すんです
こうやってすごい爆破を起こすんです
だから原子炉でウランの働きも
原子爆弾でプルトニウムの働きも同じことで
まずちょこっと刺激を与える
それからもうもうもうたまったもんじゃないんです
我々もちょっと一言聞く
誰かからね あなたがあなたはね
本当に初めからすごい嫌いですよとかね
それだけで十分です 誰かあんたには本当にうるさいねとか
それ聞いただけで結構です
それから私は爆破しますよと
原子炉が それって我々経験済みでしょ？実証済みでしょ
だからわかるでしょ 心は自力で動くんだと
自立自力も因縁なので自由ではありません
それ私はあまり単語を知らないんだから
そういう風に書いてましたけど
あの心は自立自力で動くんだけど
その自立自力も因縁なんです
例えば ウランは自分でウラン分子が機能して爆破しますけど
因縁なんです たっけ？ニュートロンじゃなくて
えっ？中性子 あっ そうですね
だからニュートロンが飛んで飛んで飛んで
この核をね 攻撃しなくちゃ
核の中に入り込めなくちゃいけないんです
核の中に入り込んだら
核がばれちゃうんですね
それですごいエネルギーが出るんですね
それからたくさん中性子が出るんですね
大量に この大量の中性子がまた次の次の核の中に入り込んじゃうんです
それでまたたくさん みるみるうちにドーンとやっちゃいます
あっという間に それ自力なんですけど
因縁なんです だから自由ってことは使えない
まあ言葉のどうでもいいんですよ
一応 はい 肉体の状態 はっ
えーと 今日はもう話は整理をしないみたい
あの結晶 新たに生命が現れることの時
現れることですね 結晶っていうのは
新たに魂が生命が誕生すること
過去の業によって これから成長する体の基本的な形
状態を定めるんです まあ簡単に言ってもわかりやすいですね
我々はこの世で生まれる時は
生まれる瞬間である形が決めるんです
はい この形だと まだまだわからないんです
もう細胞ではなくて 原子レベルだからね
それが過去の業が決めておくんです
それからその人はもう成長するでしょ
お腹の中で栄養もらって
栄養もらって もうそれから生まれて
お母さんからもうおっぱい吸って
で それ何かの形に大きくなっていくんですよ
この人間にしたっても
動物にしたっても この基本的な形
かわいい犬になるか デブの犬になるか
足が短いになるかとか
この基本的な あのベーシックパターンですね
それが生まれる瞬間に決めるんです
過去の業が 業も心に蓄積するポテンシャルです
業っていうのは心の中にあるエネルギーのことなんです
だから生まれるということは心が誕生するんです
物質のことじゃないんです
形ができたら人間だというならばね
泥でも作れますよ 心がないんですね
だから心が入ったら人間であるで
そういうことで業ということになるんですね
人が死ぬまで様々な業が体の構成を変化させます
それからあのスタート時点で業が決めますけど
それから生きている上でも業
業するんですね 行為をするんですね
それによってあのプログラムは微妙に変わったりする
皆様 携帯を買っても それにも店にあるあの貼る貼るものは全部貼って貼って貼ってね
だから女性の携帯なんか見てみると
まあ見ない方がいいんですね
特に若い女の子たちの携帯なんかは何が貼っているかわからないぐらい
もうもう場所もないんですね
いろんなものを貼ってデザインしていますよ
そういう感じで 我々はこの体を新しい業で適適当に変えます
が 女性女の子たちがね
いろんなステッカー貼って
なんかガラス玉も貼っちゃうんですね
いろんなものを貼って
なんかすごいアクセサリーみたいなね
美しい携帯にするんだけど
メーカーは変えられませんし
機能は変えられませんし
そもそも携帯には変わりはないし
あのパンチボードっていうか
あのキーをそのまま放っておかなくちゃいけない
キーの上も貼っちゃうと結構壊れます
だからある程度で変えられます
例えば男性ならこのもうイヤホンを挿したりして
これで携帯を耳元に持ってこないんですね
ポケットに入れたままでそのまま喋るとかね
それでみんな あの人頭おかしいとかね
一人で勝手に喋ってるんだとか思ったりもするし
まあとにかくまあその程度はできますけどね
それ以上はできない それから
環境によっても体が変わる
2番目 環境 生きてる環境によっても体が変わる
日本のお母さんとお父さん
日本のお母さんが 例えば自分の国
スリランカに行って子供を産む
それから子供をその国で育ててみると
かなり日本人と違う体になります
本人が言わない限り 私は日本人だと見抜きはできません
環境で変わります あるいはアメリカで産んで
そこで大きくなったら
見る限りアメリカ人であって
で アメリカ人にしてみたらちょっと変だけど
まあよくわからへんということになっちゃうんですね
それであなたは私は本当は日本人ですよと言わなくちゃいけないんです
だから 環境によっても体が変わる
肉体に取り入れる物質
栄養ですね によっても体が変化するんです
この体っていうのは 肉体に入れる物質によっても変わってしまいますね
だからテレビ あのショッピングでね
いろいろ売ってますよ
これでは 20年若返りますよとかね
だからまた他の品物を買ったら
また 15年若返りします
両方買っちゃえばね  20 たす 15 だから 35 年若返りします
で 肉体の状態ですね 次
心 認識によっても体が変わるんです
次が怖いこと 認識あります
思考 思考によっても体が変わるんです
だから美しく見せたいならば
悪い思考をするんじゃないんです
心の中で考えるもので
誰にバレませんね 何考えたってと思ってるでしょ？体が変化するんです
これ どうにもなりません
決してかわいく美しく笑うことできませんよ
こいつを殺してやりたいと思いながらね
こいつを何としてでも殺してやりたいと
ほら どうお元気ですか？とかね
せっかく来て本当に嬉しいわとか言えませんよ
すぐバレます というわけで
体が 4つの原因で絶えず変化していくんです
体っていうのは 個体的なものじゃないんです
川と同じです 台風と同じです
ずっと変わるんです 変わる原因
4つあるんです  4つが変えているんです
体は 業と心と環境と認識
結晶した業も徐々に減るので
だから体は生まれ 生まれさせた業が
パワーが それから減っていくんですね
体に入る栄養も変化するんですね
環境によっても変わるんですね
体が 汚れた心が汚れた物質を作るんですからね
そういう悪いことをね
人間の場合は 1 日の思考の 90%は汚れた思考でしょ
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにということは
強引に言っても 1 日 10 分しかやらないんです
他全部殺してやるぞとか
潰してやるぞとか その思考も体に物質作るんですよ
物質にもエントロピーっていうものがあるんです
作った物質にも ですから
老いと死っていうのは決定的
どうにもならんということです
すごく難しいポイントなんですけどね
まあ飛ばしましょう で
そういうことで私は何言いたがってるかというと
まず心の状況を説明しました
心っていうのはすごい臆病者で偉くない
依存しています 物質に
体なんですかね 体もどうったことない
変化するはするはするわ
それで壊れてエントロピーで老いて死んでしまうわと
だからお互い相互依存で生きているんです
はい